hey I'm Craig and this is my office
barium in the black shirt I lead teams
that create large-scale apps we always
start building a new app by asking
ourselves the same question what is the
customer need from us now but with this
many teams collaborating and each team
owning a different part of the app it's
difficult to get to market quickly our
cloud platform keeps us focused on
continuous integration and continuous
delivery faster than we could before we
depend upon the platform to support our
evolving open-source needs and our work
is protected at every step with platform
security that's built in not added as an
afterthought so no matter how large we
scale continuing to delight our
customers remains the top priority and
unlike other platforms powers is built
to guarantee that we own our data our
developers have the flexibility to
leverage the languages and tools they
love so we can deliver great customer
experiences in perfect harmony with
increased DevOps velocity with IBM cloud
we don't miss a beat